Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new MCU Marvel Ghost
Rider video Marvel is working on a new
project they just announced what's going
on and I'll explain what's going on with
that cancelled Ghost Rider TV show that
they were about to start filming last
year before they called stop on it so if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the easter-egg
videos we're doing an Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know where do you
want to see ghost riders show up in the
MCU first I know everyone's crossing
their fingers for Doctor Strange to
multiverse of madness don't worry I'll
talk about how this all fits into this
supernatural side of the MCU that Kevin
Feige was talking about earlier last
year so just going down the list
starting with number 5 it was recently
announced that Marvel was working on a
new Ghost Rider project that was
separate from the Ghost Rider TV show
that they were developing last year
Marvel mysteriously canceled that show
it was with Gabriel Lunas character the
Robbie Reyes version of Ghost Rider he's
the third version of Ghost Rider in the
comics it goes Johnny Blaze Danny ketch
then Robbie Reyes the way they're
describing the new Ghost Rider project
is that it could just be another Disney
Plus Ghost Rider series or it could wind
up being a full-blown MCU movie just
depending on who they're able to lock
down as the new Ghost Rider don't worry
I'll get to that too in a second because
there been a lot of big rumors about who
Marvel is trying to lock down as their
new Ghost Rider but we already have a
Ghost Rider in the MCU right now it's
Robbie Reyes they debuted him during
agents of shield season 4 you all
probably remember they did his MCU
backstory and then before Avengers
infinity war started they sort of wrote
him off into a larger supernatural war
that had been going on in another
dimension so that's why you didn't see
him a whole lot
after that they even did a Coulson
version of the Ghost Rider character he
took the spirit of vengeance into him
that was actually a pretty fun moment
because agents of shield is meant to be
connected to the MCU you can argue in
the comments over whether or not you
think that Coulson Ghost Rider is now
the fourth version of Ghost Rider what
was going to happen after that though is
that they were going to bring the Robbie
Reyes ghost rider back is the main
version to our earth for a Ghost Rider
TV series they were making is part of a
larger team up adventure into fear
series so it was going to be like Marvel's
Netflix defenders with a bunch of TV
shows crossing over but it was going to
be a more midnight Suns spin on that
take they had a health
TV showed that they were also developing
as part of that too that I'll talk about
in a second the way they describe them
is that it was going to be part of their
spirits of vengeance multiple spirits of
vengeance they wrote all the scripts for
that series and they were about to start
rolling cameras last year filming it
when it was abruptly cancelled outright
the actor was released from his contract
so now it doesn't seem like Gabriel Luna
is going to be doing any ghostwriter stuff
anytime soon there were a couple reasons
why Marvel did that as part of their
larger reorganization behind the scenes
in the way they're developing new MCU
projects for Disney Plus and for the
movies they're not completely retconning
Robbie Reyes' character out in favor of
a new Ghost Rider reboot with Johnny
Blaze it's a little more complicated
than that so this is the actual origin
story of the current MCU ghost rider
Robbie Reyes
I begged the universe I
begged anyone who would listen and you
be spared I swore that I'd give
anything to save you then I heard a
voice
was asking me if I wanted a second
chance did I want to punish those who
hurt my brother did I want to avenge my
own death
I answered yes
more than anything yes. There was someone there when
I came to
It was the devil.
Whatever was inside him he passed into me
Ghost Rider
On the show they were trying
to be as authentic to the comics as
possible so the version of Ghost Rider
that saved his life transferring the
spirit of vengeance into him was
supposed to be Danny ketch since he was
the spirit of vengeance after Johnny
Blaze they briefly alluded to the
history of the dark hold in the original
Ghost Rider during the show but aside
from visiting Johnny blazes house and
seeing a bunch of Johnny Blaze Easter
eggs in the basement we never really saw
a version of that character on the show
so for the new Ghost Rider project that
Marvel is developing for the MCU would
be a new version of Johnny Blaze they're
not going to be bringing Nicolas Cage
back as the character although it would
be cool to see him cameo in the
background to some sort of Easter egg
the current rumor is that it's actually
one of the projects that Keanu Reeves
met with Marvel about last year oh yeah
ha ha
yes oh when we heard that Keanu was
meeting with marble naturally everybody
was asking Kevin Feige about it in
interviews he said that they meet with
him after every big Avengers movie at
the start of new Marvel phases just to
see if there's any upcoming interest and
Marvel characters or any good fits for
him inside upcoming movies Kevin Feige
never said which past characters he
would have played had he said yes to
something because his John wick movies
have been blowing up so big the last
several years he's mostly been too busy
with those to do anything with marble
they're still making John wick for even
though a lot of stuff has been delayed
because of the virus but after that
would be when he'd be available for new
MCU projects so number 3 the reason why
Ghost Rider is so special for him is
because of his love of motorcycles there
was even a documentary recently on his
history with bikes they even gave a
special behind-the-scenes tour of the
custom motorcycle shop that he owns
himself in Los Angeles before there was
arts motorcycle there was Reeves looking
to customize a harley-davidson I was
introduced to guard hollinger God agreed
to customize a bike but then went so
much further
basically just keeping the engine and
designing everything else from scratch
it was no longer a Harley Davidson was
becoming a chop rods motorcycle which
was
company that guard had so he rides bikes
all the time between movies and he even
bought custom motorcycles for the entire
stunt crew of the John wick movies
that's how hardcore a motorcycle fan he
is so of course it makes sense that he
could become the next rider in the MCU
next big thing to right now the
supernatural timeline of the MCU works
like this they do Doctor Strange two
multiverse of madness first with Doctor
Strange Scarlet Witch team up against
what seems like the villain nightmare
from the nightmare dimension Sam Raimi
mr. spider-man himself is directing that
he has a deep history with horror comedy
and big superhero movies so I'm really
happy that he's the one that Marvel
picked to take over the project that
movie's supposed to introduce more
traditional horror elements and
supernatural characters from the comics
setting the stage for the Blade movie
which is rumored to be coming out
October 2022 right now if there aren't
any more delays they already announced
my herschel Ally is the new blade of the
MCU but they didn't say if he'd cameo
and Doctor Strange 2 or some other
Marvel movie before they do the
straight-up blade reboot movie by the
time they get ready to make that blade
movie they'll also have released the new
moon knight Marvel Disney Plus series
that's the big supernatural MCU Disney
Plus series all the Disney Plus
characters will eventually cross over
into the movies and it seems like
they're slowly planning on a Marvel
hearts of Darkness midnight Suns type of
crossover movie further down into Marvel
phase four with all these supernatural
characters when marbles deciding what's
going to be a movie or what's going to be a
Disney plus series usually just depends
on how bankable it winds up being how
big the actors they get so they get some
really big actors to play some of these
supernatural characters then it's more
likely that that would turn into a movie
then a Disney Plus series but those big
supernatural crossovers it's where you
start to see actual Ghost Rider MCU
stuff happening and for those of you
that are waiting for Mephisto to show up
in the MCU in a big way like Mephisto
versus Doctor Strange in a future movie
Mephisto is also the person who made the
original contract with Johnny Blaze
binding the spirit of vengeance to him
so everyone keep your eyes peeled for
Easter eggs for all that stuff when
Doctor Strange 2 comes out but number
one I know a lot of you are asking
what's going to happen with that other
Robby Rhea's Ghost Rider in the MCU
right now it doesn't seem like Marvel
has any big plans to use
again right away but the way they're
currently treating all the pre-existing
Marvel TV characters is that they're
mostly in an alternate reality or in the
case of agents of shield characters
they're stuck in a different part of the
timeline so they're not completely
wrecked conned out sidelined is a better
way to think about it while they figure
out what they're going to do with a lot of
them really good example is there been
reports that the quake character might
make the jump to an agents of sword
Disney Plus series based around Nick
Fury's new sword Space Station but
Marvel hasn't officially announced that
series yet there would be their big
agents of shield replacement since
they're getting ready to introduce sword
in the Wanda vision series and Marvel is
still supposed to release that hellström
series they already filmed all 10
episodes and they're supposed to be on
Hulu at some point later this year or
next year but as you can see Marvel is
just making a big play into the
supernatural as Kevin Feige said at
Comic Con last year blade is just the
first really big movie that they have
planned as part of that after Doctor
Strange 2 but Doctor Strange 2 is really
where you first start to see that stuff
happening everyone let me know in the
comments who do you want to play the
brand-new version of Johnny Blaze Ghost
Rider in the MCU if we get any other big
casting news for other big Marvel
characters of course I'll do videos
about it but congratulations to Carlos
PD as you're the giveaway winner from my
last big Marvel video please email me on
the about page of my channel so I can
get your details
everyone click here for my brand-new
Deadpool 3 Ryan Reynolds clip and click
here for my new marvel x-men video and
new mutants trailer thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe.
I'll see you guys tonight!